Sur la simplicité. Quelle belle façon de commencer.
Je surveille cette tendance, ces parutions
de livres intitulés "Tel ou tel sujet Pour Les Nuls".
Vous connaissez ces livres, "Tel ou tel sujet Pour Les Nuls" ?
Mes filles trouvent que je lui ressemble beaucoup, c'est un peu problématique.
(Rires)
J'en ai cherché d'autres de ce genre sur Amazon.com.
Saviez-vous qu'il existe aussi un livre appelé "Le Guide du Parfait Idiot" ?
Il semble qu'il y ait un marché sur le fait d'être idiot.
Nous aimons que la technologie nous fasse nous sentir mal, curieusement.
Mais j'aime vraiment ça, alors j'ai écrit un livre intitulé "Les lois de la simplicité".
J'étais à Milan la semaine dernière, pour le lancement en Italie.
Ce livre pose des questions sur la simplicité.
Il y a très peu de réponses. Moi-même, je me demande, qu'est-ce que la simplicité?
Est-ce bien ? Est-ce mal ? La complexité vaut-elle mieux ? Je ne suis pas sûr.
Après avoir écrit "Les lois de la simplicité",
la simplicité me fatiguait, comme vous pouvez l'imaginer.
Dans ma vie, j'ai découvert que savoir prendre des vacances
est la meilleure compétence de tout type d'acharné du travail.
Parce que votre travail prendra toujours toute votre vie,
mais il ne pourra jamais prendre vos vacances -- en théorie.
(Rires)
Je suis donc allé au cap Cod l'été dernier pour fuir la simplicité,
et je suis passé chez Gap car je n'avais que des pantalons noirs.
J'étais donc parti m'acheter un short kaki ou je ne sais quoi,
et je tombe sur leur slogan, "Faites simple".
(Rires)
J'ai ouvert un magazine, et le slogan de Visa était :
"Le business conduit à la simplicité".
Je développe des photos, et Kodak dit : "Faites simple".
La simplicité avait l'air de me suivre partout, c'était bizarre.
J'ai alors allumé la télé, je la regarde très peu en général,
et vous connaissez cette personne -- c'est Paris Hilton, oui.
Elle présentait cette émission "The Simple Life".
J'ai regardé. Ce n'est pas si simple en fait, un peu confus.
(Rires)
J'ai cherché autre chose à voir.
Alors j'ai ouvert cette sorte de guide pour télé.
Et j'ai vu que sur la chaîne E!, l'émission "Simple life" est très populaire.
Ils vont le diffuser encore, encore et plus encore.
(Rires)
C'était traumatisant, en fait.
J'ai voulu m'échapper, alors je suis parti en voiture.
Au cap Cod, il y a des routes idylliques. Vous savez tous conduire, ici.
Sur la route, ces panneaux sont très importants.
Celui-ci est très simple, il dit : "Route", et "Route approchant".
Je suis donc en train de rouler, tout va bien, et je vois ce panneau.
(Rires)
La complexité semblait m'attaquer soudainement,
et là que je me suis dit : "Quand même, la simplicité, c'est important."
Puis je me suis demandé : "Tiens, et sur une plage, à quoi ressemblerait-elle, la simplicité ?
Si le ciel était à 41% gris -- ne serait-ce pas un ciel parfait?"
Le ciel de la simplicité, j'entends.
Car en réalité le ciel ressemblait à ça. C'était un ciel magnifique, complexe.
Vous savez, avec du rose et du bleu. On ne peut pas s'empêcher d'aimer la complexité.
Nous sommes des êtres humains, nous aimons les choses complexes.
Nous aimons les histoires d'amour. C'est très compliqué. Et nous aimons ce genre de chose.
Je me trouve à cet endroit appelé Media Lab.
Peut-être que certains d'entre vous en ont entendu parler.
Il a été conçu par I. M. Pei, l'un des plus grands architectes modernes.
Le modernisme, ça signifie des boîtes blanches, et il s'agit en effet d'une parfaite boîte blanche.
(Rires)
Certains d'entre vous êtes des entrepreneurs, ou autres.
Le mois dernier j'étais chez Google et, mon dieu, cette cafétéria.
Si vous voulez vous pouvez avoir des sortes de stock options là-bas, dans la Silicon Valley.
Mais dans les universités, on obtient des titres, plein de titres.
L'année dernière à TED, c'était tous mes titres. J'avais plein de titres.
Il en manque un, en tant que père d'un groupe de filles.
Cette année à TED, je suis heureux d'annoncer que j'ai de nouveaux titres
en plus des précédents.
Encore un en tant que Directeur de recherche associé.
Et un autre événement : j'ai maintenant 5 filles.
(Rires)
Mon bébé Reina. Merci.
Ma vie est bien plus complexe à cause du bébé, d'ailleurs,
mais ça va. Nous resterons mariés, je pense.
Mais retournons en arrière, quand j'étais enfant
-- j'ai grandi dans une usine de tofu à Seattle.
Beaucoup d'entre vous n'aiment peut-être pas le tofu parce que vous n'en avez pas goûté de bon,
mais le tofu est une bonne nourriture, très simple.
C'est un travail très difficile de faire du tofu.
Nous avions l'habitude de nous lever à 1h du matin, et de travailler jusqu'à 6h du soir, 6 jours par semaine.
Mon père était une sorte d'Andy Grove, paranoïaque de la compétition.
Alors c'était souvent sept jours par semaine. Business familial égale travail des enfants.
Nous étions un grand modèle. Et j'adorais aller à l'école.
L'école c'était super. Et peut-être que l'école
m'a aidé à atteindre ce Media Lab, allez savoir.
(Rires)
Merci.
Le Media Lab est un endroit intéressant, et important pour moi.
J'étais étudiant en informatique, au départ,
et j'ai découvert le design plus tard dans ma vie.
Il y a eu cette personne, Muriel Cooper.
Qui connait Muriel Cooper ? Muriel Cooper ?
N'était-elle pas étonnante? Muriel Cooper. Elle était complètement loufoque.
Elle avait exactement l'esprit de TED, et elle nous a montré --
elle a montré au monde comment faire de l'ordinateur un bel objet.
Et elle compte beaucoup pour moi.
C'est elle qui m'a dit de quitter le MIT pour aller en école d'art.
C'est le meilleur conseil que j'ai jamais reçu. J'ai donc fait une école d'art grâce à elle.
Elle est décédée en 1994
et j'ai été rappelé au MIT pour prendre sa place. Mais c'est tellement dur.
Extraordinaire personne, Muriel Cooper.
Quand j'étais au Japon -- mon école d'art était au Japon --
j'avais une bonne situation, j'étais directement lié à Paul Rand.
Certains d'entre vous connaissent Paul Raul,
le plus grand designer graphique sur Terre -- pas moins.
Le grand designer graphique Paul Rand
a conçu le logo d'IBM, celui de Westinghouse --
il disait tout simplement "j'ai tout conçu".
Ikko Tanaka a aussi été un mentor très important dans ma vie --
le Paul Rand japonais. Il a dessiné la plupart des grandes icônes du Japon
comme l'étiquette d'Issey Miyake, ou encore celle de Muji.
Quand vous avez des mentors
-- hier Kareem Abdul-Jabbar a parlé des mentors,
ces piliers dans vos vies -- le problème avec les mentors est qu'ils meurent tous.
C'est triste, mais une bonne chose en un sens,
car vous pouvez vous rappeler d'eux sous leur forme idéale.
Je pense que les mentors, nous en avons tous, nous humanisent en quelque sorte.
Quand vous grandissez, par exemple, et que cela vous effraie,
les mentors nous rassurent.
Je suis reconnaissant envers mes mentors, et je pense que vous l'êtes aussi.
L'aspect humain est très dur quand vous êtes au MIT.
Le T n'est pas là pour "humain", mais pour "technologie".
Et je me suis toujours posé des questions à ce sujet.
J'ai régulièrement tapé le terme "humain" sur Google,
pour voir combien de réponses j'obtenais.
En 2001 j'en obtenais 26 millions. Et pour "ordinateur",
car les ordinateurs sont un peu contre les humains,
j'en avais 42 millions. Permettez-moi faire mon Al Gore ici.
Essayons de comparer les choses, comme ça,
vous pouvez visualiser la lutte "ordinateur contre humain"
-- j'ai traqué cela l'année dernière --
le rapport "ordinateur contre 'humain" a changé au cours de cette année.
Avant, il y avait une proportion de "deux pour un". Maintenant les humains rattrapent leur retard.
Très bien, nous les humains sommes en train de rattraper les ordinateurs.
Avec la simplicité, c'est aussi intéressant,
si vous comparez le complexe à la simplicité,
cette dernière est aussi en train regagner du terrain.
Les humains et la simplicité sont en quelque sorte entremêlés, je pense.
Mais je dois l'avouer : je ne suis pas un homme de simplicité.
J'ai passé l'intégralité de mon début de carrière à faire du complexe.
Beaucoup de choses complexes.
J'ai écrit des programmes informatiques pour produire des graphiques comme celui-ci.
Certains clients japonais me demandaient de réaliser des choses vraiment complexes.
Et je me suis toujours senti gêné par cela, quelque part.
Alors je me suis caché dans une dimension temporelle :
j'ai produit des choses dans une dimension graphique temporelle.
J'ai fait cette série de calendriers pour Shiseido.
Un calendrier au thème floral, en 1997,
et là un feu d'artifice. Vous lancez le nombre dans l'espace.
En fait les Japonais pensent que quand vous voyez des feux d'artifice
vous vous rafraîchissez, curieusement.
C'est pourquoi ils font des feux d'artifice l'été.
Une culture très extrême.
Enfin, un calendrier d'automne.
J'ai beaucoup de feuilles dans mon jardin.
Il s'agit donc des feuilles de mon jardin, essentiellement.
J'ai fait beaucoup de choses de ce genre.
J'ai eu la chance d'avoir été là avant que d'autres le fassent,
et je suis donc l'auteur de tous ces trucs qui vous abîment les yeux.
Je ne me sens pas très bien à cet égard.
Demain, Paola Antonelli interviendra. J'adore Paola.
Elle tient une exposition en ce moment au MoMA,
certains de ses travaux de jeunesse sont exposés sur les murs.
Si vous êtes à New York, je vous conseille vraiment d'aller voir ça.
J'ai eu un problème du fait d'avoir produit tous ces trucs volants.
Les gens disent "Ah oui, je connais votre travail,
vous êtes le type qui fait du régal pour les yeux. [littéralement - bonbon pour les yeux]"
Quand vous entendez cela, vous vous sentez bizarre.
Du bonbon pour les yeux -- c'est péjoratif quelque part, vous ne trouvez pas ?
Je réponds "Non, j'en fais de la viande", plutôt.
(Rires)
Faire de la viande c'est différent, c'est plus fibreux,
peut-être plus puissant. Mais qu'est-ce que ça pourrait être, en fait, de la viande pour les yeux?
Je me suis toujours intéressé aux algorithmes informatiques.
Les algorithmes informatiques sont essentiellement des arbres,
et quand vous faites de l'art avec, cela pose problème.
Avec un programme informatique, même si vous faites de l'art,
vous restez sur l'arbre. Et le paradoxe c'est que
pour réellement créer, vous devez vous dégager de cet arbre.
Voilà une sorte de complication que j'ai remarquée.
Alors pour sortir de l'arbre, j'ai commencé à utiliser mes vieux ordinateurs.
J'ai pris ceux-ci à Tokyo en 2001 pour faire des objets informatiques.
C'est une nouvelle façon de taper, sur mon vieux Classic couleur.
Vous ne pouvez pas taper beaucoup là-dessus.
J'ai aussi découvert que les souris optiques répondaient aux émissions des tubes cathodiques,
et pouvaient ainsi bouger toutes seules, ce qui donne des machines à dessin automatiques.
Une année, aussi, avec le Mac G3 bondi bleu,
le caisson s'est relevé comme, dangereux, comme déjanté quoi.
Je me suis dit "C'est très intéressant. Et si je faisais un crash-test, comme avec les voitures ?"
J'ai donc fait un crash-test.
(Rires)
Une sorte d'évaluation d'impact. C'est le genre de chose que je fais.
Juste pour essayer de comprendre comment les choses fonctionnent.
(Rires)
Peu de temps après, les attentats du 9 septembre eurent lieu, ce qui m'a beaucoup déprimé.
Je m'intéressais à l'art contemporain,
qui ne parlait que de pisse, et autres genres de trucs plutôt tristes,
et j'ai alors voulu faire quelque chose de joyeux.
Je me suis concentré sur la nourriture, pour en faire mon domaine --
du genre de ce qu'on fait avec des peaux de clémentine.
Au Japon, c'est merveilleux de retourner les peaux de clémentine
d'une seule pièce. Qui a déjà fait ça ? Clémentine d'une pièce?
Ah, vous ratez beaucoup si vous ne l'avez jamais fait.
C'était très bon, et j'ai découvert que je pouvais faire des sculptures avec,
de différentes formes.
Si vous les séchez rapidement, vous pouvez faire des éléphants, des veaux, d'autres trucs,
mais ma femme n'aimait pas ça parce que ça moisissait, j'ai donc dû arrêter.
Je suis donc retourné à mon ordinateur, j'ai acheté cinq grosses frites,
et je les ai scannées. Je cherchais une sorte de thématique culinaire,
alors j'ai écrit des programmes pour générer automatiquement des images de frites.
Quand j'étais enfant, j'écoutais cette chanson, vous savez,
"C'est beau, pour les ciels spacieux, pour les ondes ambrées de grains"
alors j'ai illustré cette idée d'ondes ambrées.
C'est une sorte de champ de frites du Midwest.
Quand j'étais enfant, j'étais le plus gros de la classe,
et j'adorais les Cheetos. Ah, j'adore les Cheetos, miam.
Et je voulais jouer avec des Cheetos, en quelque sorte.
Je n'étais pas sûr de savoir où aller avec ça, mais j'ai inventé Cheetos paint.
Cheeto paint est une façon très simple de peindre avec des Cheetos.
(Rires)
J'ai découvert que les Cheetos sont un très bon moyen d'expression.
Et avec ces Cheetos, j'ai commencé à réfléchir,
"Qu'est-ce que je peux faire avec ces Cheetos?"
J'ai commencé à gondoler des morceaux de chips et des bretzels.
Je recherchais une sorte de forme,
et à la fin j'ai fait 100 patapillons. Vous saisissez?
(Rires)
Et chaque patapillon est composé de différentes pièces.
Les gens me demandent de quoi sont faites les antennes.
Ce sont mes cheveux. Parfois on en trouve, dans la nourriture.
Mes cheveux sont propres, pas de souci.
Je suis un professeur titulaire, ce qui signifie simplement que je n'ai plus à travailler.
C'est un business model assez étrange. Je vais au travail chaque jour
je coupe cinq bouts de papier et je les regarde en prenant mon café au lait.
Fin de l'histoire.
(Rires)
Mais j'ai réalisé que la vie pouvait vraiment être ennuyeuse,
j'ai un peu réfléchi à la vie, et j'ai remarqué un truc avec mon appareil photo
-- appareil photo numérique versus voiture -- un truc très étrange.
La voiture est tellement grande, l'appareil photo est tellement petit,
et le manuel pour l'appareil photo est tellement plus gros que celui de la voiture.
Ça n'a pas de sens.
(Rires)
Bref. J'étais donc au cap Cod une fois, et j'ai tapé le mot "simplicité".
Et j'ai découvert de façon bizarre, à la Mr Night Shyamalan,
que cela révélait les lettres "M-I-T". Vous voyez le mot?
Dans les termes "simplicité" et complexité", "M-I-T" apparaît en séquences parfaites.
C'est étrange n'est-ce pas?
Je me suis dit que ça allait encore m'occuper pour vingt ans au moins.
Et j'ai écrit ce livre "Les lois de la simplicité" --
c'est un livre simple, très court. Il contient dix lois et trois clés.
Les dix lois et trois clés, je ne vais pas les détailler car j'ai fait un livre pour cela,
et vous pourrez le trouver gratuitement en ligne.
Les lois ressemblent à des sushi : il y en a de toutes sortes.
Au Japon, ils disent que le sushi est un défi.
Voyez le uni, c'est le plus gros défi. Le nombre 10 est un défi --
les gens détestent le nombre 10 comme ils détestent le uni, en fait.
Les trois clés sont faciles à manger, ce sont des anago, déjà cuits, faciles à manger.
Pensez aux "Lois de la simplicité" en dégustant votre prochain repas de sushi.
Car je veux vous simplifier la vie.
Et puisqu'il s'agit de cela, je me dois de simplifier les choses.
Simplifions donc "Les lois de la simplicité".
J'ai un truc qui s'appelle "cookie versus linge".
Tous ceux qui ont des enfants le savent : si vous proposez à un enfant
un grand cookie ou un petit cookie,
lequel va-t-il prendre ? Le grand cookie.
Vous pouvez dire que le petit cookie contient des morceaux de chocolat Godiva,
cela n'aura aucun effet. Ils veulent le grand cookie.
Mais si vous proposez aux enfants deux piles de linge à plier,
entre la petite et la grande pile, laquelle choisiront-ils?
étonnamment, pas la grande. Et je pense que c'est aussi simple que cela.
Quand vous en voulez plus, c'est parce que cela vous plaît,
quand vous en voulez moins, c'est parce qu'il s'agit de travail.
Pour résumer, la simplicité revient à vivre sa vie
de la façon la plus amusante, avec le moins de peine possible.
Je pense qu'il s'agit simplement d'une sorte de "plus versus moins".
Et en gros, tout dépend toujours de cela.
J'ai voulu écrire ce livre parce que je voulais comprendre la vie.
J'aime la vie. J'aime être en vie. J'adore observer les choses.
Et la vie est un point important, je pense, en termes de simplicité.
Car on essaie toujours de se simplifier la vie.
J'adore simplement voir le monde. Le monde est un endroit incroyable.
En étant à TED, nous voyons tellement de choses à la fois.
Je ne peux pas m'empêcher d'aimer voir tout ce qui existe.
Tout ce que vous voyez, chaque fois que vous vous réveillez.
Tout est sujet à une telle expérience de joie.
Tout, d'un hall d'hôtel bizarre,
au cellophane qui remplace votre fenêtre,
en passant par ce moment où sur la route pavée de noir, devant chez moi,
se trouvait ce papillon blanc, en train de mourir au soleil.
Tout cela réveille chez moi l'excitation d'être ici,
car la vie a une fin.
Cela m'a été donné par le président de Shiseido.
C'est un expert du vieillissement. Cet axe horizontal donne votre âge --
12 ans, 24 ans, 74, 96 ans --
et ça, ce sont des données médicales. La force du cerveau augmente jusqu'à 60 ans,
et après 60, elle tend à baisser. Une sorte de dépression, d'une certaine manière.
C'est la même chose pour votre force physique.
Vous savez, j'ai de nombreux étudiants de première année au MIT, très arrogants, à qui je dis,
"Votre corps est vraiment de plus en plus fort, c'est vrai,
mais vers la fin de la vingtaine et milieu de la trentaine, les cellules meurent."
OK. Cela les fait travailler plus dur, parfois.
Si vous avez toutes vos capacités de vision, la vision c'est intéressant.
Plus vous êtes jeune et meilleure est votre vue.
A l'adolescence, début de la vingtaine, vous cherchez un mari ou une femme,
et votre vision s'en va.
(Rires)
Votre rôle dans la société, c'est aussi très intéressant.
En vieillissant vous pouvez, par exemple, avoir des enfants. Ou peu importe quoi.
Les enfant sont ensuite diplômés, et vous n'avez plus de responsabilités
- ce qui est très bien aussi.
Mais si certains d'entre vous se demandent,
"Que faisons-nous, finalement ? Nous reste-t-il quelque chose ?
Que retirer de tout cela ?" Je pense que la sagesse se construit en permanence.
J'aime ces hommes et ces femmes de 80, 90 ans.
Ils ont tellement d'esprit, tellement de sagesse,
et je crois -- vous voyez, je suis là, au TED.
C'est la quatrième fois, et je crois que je viens pour cette sagesse.
Ce ensemble d'effets que procure TED tire votre sagesse vers le haut, en quelque sorte.
Je suis content d'être là et très reconnaissant, Chris.
C'est une expérience incroyable pour moi aussi.